another group break news we can bring
you and this is regarding uh the death
of morel Stark she is the primary school
teacher who was found dead along with
her unborn child last week in mugdoc in
Scotland uh her ex-partner was also
found his body was recovered from a lake
at mug dog park a short while later
while her parents have now made a
statement they say that they are
devastated following the death of our
daughter Morel and soon to be grandson
that Jaden sturrick they go on to say
that she was the happiest person you
could ever meet and was always looking
to help others the best she could
Morrell and her partner doted on each
other this incident has come as a total
shock to all who knew her we'd like to
thank family and friends colleagues at
sandwood Primary School police Scotland
officers both in the highlands and
Glasgow for their efforts comforting and
supporting following this tragic event
our family would like to ask everyone
including the press to expect of respect
our privacy at this very sad and
difficult time so a brief statement
there from Morel sturrick's parents
Colin and Lorna sturrick following the
death of their daughter and soon to be
grandson last week